families are hard especially big
gatherings because you will disagree and
fight over anything and everything beat
career choices politics or even things
like the decision to subscribe to the
new old review and thus receive regular
Georgia content uploaded straight into
your YouTube feed because you know
there's always that one weird uncle who
just doesn't want to do it so don't be a
weird uncle hit the button hello and
welcome to the new order video source
for everything anime and manga and today
it's time to delve deep into George's
bizarre adventure quite specifically to
examine the Joestar family tree now I
know there are other videos on the
internet covering this but to be honest
I don't care this is as much to solidify
my own understanding of the series as it
is yours whilst the other videos don't
have a sarcastic Australian man
narrating so we're all just going to sit
here comfortably and enjoy the story of
this complicated family before getting
into things though I should say that
this is going to be a comprehensive
family tree meaning that it will include
members all the way through to part 6
beings don't ocean now I have tried to
do my best to avoid any blatant spoilers
of part 6 for anime only Watchers but by
virtue of the very existence of certain
characters that's going to be well
impossible so you have been warned and
kick things off properly it may or may
not be a good idea to state that you can
generally spot a flesh-and-blood member
of the Joestar family due to a rather
conspicuous birthmark shaped like a
gigantic star which tends to appear on
the exact same area of each of their
bodies now the birthmark system may or
may not be a foolproof method to detect
Joestar and we will get into some tricky
situations that this family has gotten
themselves into in that regard but I
guess I should also point out that not
every confirmed Joestar family member
has actually revealed this visible
birthmark but it is assumed to be on
them in any case with that in mind let's
begin this bizarre family journey and
first up we will begin with George
Joestar the first he serves as the
oldest known member of the Joestar line
and he made a very decent living as a
merchant and trader who quite notably
began the Joestar connection to the
brando family through his generosity and
mercy towards one Dario Brando
now George would also eventually meet a
lovely lady whom we have only ever seen
a portrait of but we know as Mary
Joestar and wherever rather tragically
Mary would pass away whilst accompanying
George on a trip to London when their
carriage fell into a ravine
prior to her passing though Mary and
George had produced a spawn by the name
of Jonathan Joestar who was born in 1868
and would go on to become our very first
titular Jojo in bar
King on a bizarre adventure of his own
during part one of the series known as
phantom blood now Jonathan would also go
on to become an archaeologist and were
he not quite possibly the most
unfortunate man in all of media I'm sure
that he would have developed quite a
profound career in that field
however Jonathan would not be an only
child oddly enough as due to giorgo
star's connection to the Brander family
another child would be adopted into the
household named dear Brando who would
use the resources of the Joestar family
to go on to become a professional brick
although in actuality he went on to
become a lawyer
is it redundant I don't know we'll leave
that up dear in any case this was all
while he was human because do eventually
discovered the existence of a stone mask
and used its power to turn himself into
a fearsome yet flamboyant vampire in any
case deer would end up murdering George
Joestar and setting the stage for the
main conflict of part 1 with Jonathan
where do is beaten repeatedly only to
reappear and terrorize Jonathan
meanwhile Jonathan had something of a
our childhood sweethearts named Erina
Pendleton who would eventually marry
into the family and become Erina Joestar
sadly though after Erina had become
pregnant dears actions would result in
the death of Jonathan who attempted to
ensure that deer would be entered once
and for all whilst Erina would survive
with both their unborn child and another
infant who had lost their mother in the
skirmish between Jonathan and deer and I
should probably point out right now that
deer did also survive this event and he
would incorporate his disembodied
vampire head onto the body of Jonathan
Joestar thus turning do into a being
with legitimate Joestar blood and
single-handedly leading to the
excessively complex nature of the
Joestar family which we will return to
in due course but for now we're going to
keep things as simple as we can in any
case Erina and Jonathan's child was born
in 1889
and he was given the name of George
Joestar the second and he would grow up
to become a pilot in the British Air
Force generally living in less than
bizarre adventure and marrying a woman
named Elizabeth Joestar and very
interestingly Elizabeth was the baby
that Arryn and Joestar had saved and
declare up any potential witness of this
year's situation though Elizabeth was
not adopted into the Joestar family nor
did she and George grow up as siblings
Elizabeth was actually adopted by a
family friend named straight so which is
how she went on to become such a boss in
the art of home on and in case she and
George would meet and fall in love later
in life and go on to produce the ever
iconic Joseph Joestar before we get into
him though there is some sad news
regarding George a second as he was
killed by a zombie officer created by
deer after which point Elizabeth Bruce
they slaughtered said officer and went
into hiding leaving joseph under the
guardianship of his now grandmother
Erina and joseph after all this
signifies the arrival of our second
titular jojo as he helmed part two of
the series being battle tendency and a
lot of this series focused on Joseph's
training in the art of hamon in order to
defeat a new threat to the world being
The Pillowman
during the spot Joseph was trained by
his mother actually although Joseph did
not know this fact as she now went by
the name of Lisa Lisa and this led to at
least one awkward moment for the readers
and Watchers of the series at this point
though Lisa Lisa also had a maid named
Suzie Q who Joseph took quite a liking
to and after the events of battle
tendency the two of them was swiftly
married and had one daughter together
named Holly Joestar however that would
not be the end of how shall I put this
Joseph's exploits as much later on in
life he would come to have an affair
with a Japanese woman named Tomoko
higashikata which resulted in her
becoming a pregnant and giving birth to
josuke higashikata in 1983 and josuke
would be the main protagonist of part
four Diamond is unbreakable living
exclusively in the crazy noisy Bazaar
town that is Mario but even this would
not be the end of Joseph's joestar's
familial acquisitions au has on a trip
tomorrow at the age of 79
he became embroiled in the mystery of a
baby who had a stand ability that
allowed her to turn herself and
everything within a spherical diameter
invisible and this was one of those many
mysteries that was never really solved
as the baby's parents were never found
and so a very old Joseph decided to
adopt her into the family giving her the
name of Shizuka Joestar despite
potentially incurring even more wrath of
his already furious wife Suzie Q but
many of you may have noticed that we've
jumped quite a bit here talking about
all this part for business when we have
yet to even cover part three outrageous
of me to get into this so we have to
return to Joseph's daughter Holly
Joestar who fell in love with a man
named sorrow Cujo who we as an audience
have never seen but that resulted in
Holly moving to Japan becoming Holly
Cujo and giving birth to one son who had
become the general face of JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure
Jotaro Kujo and dirt road be our
protagonist to part three Stannis
Crusaders in which he his grandfather
Joseph three other dudes and a dog would
travel across the world to defeat the
new leary emerge do who is currently
using the body of Jonathan Joestar and
very notably it would be Johto who
defeated deer once and for all putting
an end to the Joestar brando shenanigan
ree or not i suppose because by this
time do
well he'd spread his seed around the
world I guess that's one way of putting
it before we get into that though we
have the final and most recent
generation of the Joestar family to deal
with as Jorah would go on to marry only
to divorce an unnamed woman but a union
would produce a daughter named Jolene
Kujo who would be out titular Georgia
for part 6 being stoned ocean where
things go so far off the rails that the
Joestar line simply does not progress
beyond Jolene I mean technically it
might but we certainly aren't privy to
that information but I am afraid that we
are far from ending this video here
because now we have to move all the way
back to do who got quite busy with
Jonathan's body most notably engaging in
the deed to produce a child in 1985 who
had become known as Johnno giovanna the
protagonist of pot 5 golden wind and
here's a fun fact due to Jonah being
produced of jonathan joestar's body he
is very technically the uncle of a very
old at this point joseph joestar as well
as the grand uncle of holly the great
granduncle of Jotaro and even more
crazily despite being only 8 years older
than Jolene this would make Jono
Jolene's great great granduncle but john
are very much acts as something of the
ultimate fusion between Joestar and
brando heritage inheriting a fair bit
from both of his familial polar
opposites to create a very unique
existence and speaking of unique
existences let's examine arguably the
most bizarre member of the Joestar
family who is known only as green baby
so this little guy exists in pond 6 and
he is born from a combination of Diaz
bone and a cluster of souls despite this
it does bear the traditional Joestar
family birthmark and really it only
exists for like a day before it fuses
with Enrico Pucci to create very strange
being indeed and here is where things
get even weirder because I guess if you
really want to you could potentially
include Enrico into the Joestar family
tree because it is technically a
physical and corporation of Joestar DNA
like what happened when Deere took over
Jonathan's body just much more
complicated and obscure and the
complications and obscurity do not stop
there because this did not just result
in a change in enrico but it also
affected his twin brother weather report
who ended up with a Joestar birthmark as
well after in Rico's fusion now the
argument for including whether a port in
the Joestar family is much more flimsy
than the one fuchi but it is kind of
undeniable that his biology did change
in some way even if it was just to give
him the birthmarks
look we're just gonna leave weather
report right here to be safe because
this is a bizarre family on a bizarre
adventure and this is a very bizarre
occurrence moving back once again to
deer though he would go on to have at
least three more children to three
different unnamed women all of whom
appear in part six that children that is
not women the first of which is
donnatella versus who according to the
Jojo wiki has an occupation of has never
been employed but in addition to him
there is also Raquel and un collar and
these three would become antagonist upon
six with an Gallo in particular wielding
an absurdly powerful stand known as
Bohemian Rhapsody a very underrated
stand by the way because a lot of people
claim that it is the easiest thing in
the world to beat because it does
provide its own to feed mechanism but
then those very same people rather
conveniently forget that if weather
report had not gotten extraordinarily
lucky and run into Vincent van Gogh who
drew a funky character of him then he
would have been destroyed by poking mean
raps T along with everyone else that is
a condensed shot of JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure right there
but with that minor rant out of the way
I think I can finally maybe safely say
that this is the entire Georgia family
tree as we currently know it and yeah
there might be some more controversial
members amongst them like Poochie and
weather report but the more I think
about it the more I've come to accept
that they were very much engulfed into
this familial heritage one way or
another very notably this family tree is
not going to explore the steel boar on
universe because I feel like we have
covered more than enough madness for one
video and if you would like me to do one
separately for that alternate universe
and please do let me know in the
comments below because there is actually
a really strange amount to explore in
that regard as well but that pretty much
does it for the Joestar family tree but
what do you guys think please do let me
know down in the comments below will
even join my discord server and if
you're keen for some voluntary content
and please do check out some of my other
videos I'll even subscribe to the
channel for regular chocho wandah
delivered straight until YouTube feed
but for now this has been the new old
review and I'll see you next time